Es ist eine der letzten Mahlzeiten,
die sich Rolf Horst Seiler
noch zubereiten kann.
Bald wird es eng.
Wie viel Geld
haben Sie noch in der Tasche?
Ich habe noch 30 Fr.
Von der Pro Senectute.
Das ist alles?
- Das ist alles.
So, Essen ist fertig.
Fertig.
Dass ihm das Wasser
bis zum Hals steht, ist nichts Neues.
Es war ein Leben lang so.
Seiler ist 76
und lebt von einer minimalen AHV
plus Ergänzungsleistungen.
Aber an dieses Geld
kommt er nicht mehr ran.
Als er kürzlich zur Bank ging,
wurde ihm mitgeteilt,
dass das Betreibungsamt
sein Konto gesperrt habe.
Wie haben Sie reagiert?
Ich sagte ...
... dann müsse ich
erst mal abklären, was los sei.
Haben Sie das Betreibungsamt
angerufen?- Nein.
Ich wusste schon, was los ist.
Ich kriege ja jede Woche ein paar
Briefe wegen dieser Betreibungen.
Ich kann keine Erfüllen.
Seiler wohnt noch nicht lange
zur Untermiete in einem Bauernhaus
in Ranflüh im Emmental.
Und schon liegt er wieder im Clinch
mit den Behörden.
Er ist eines von Tausenden von Opfern
administrativer Zwangsmassnahmen.
Er lebte fast 40 Jahre lang im Wald -
auf der Flucht vor der Gesellschaft.
Menschen misstraut er.
Tiere sind im lieber.
Hier leidet keine.
Sie haben immer Heu und Wasser.
Sie haben einen sauberen Stall.
Nichts ist verdreckt.
Alles ist sauber, immer.
Wenn ich im Wald das gehabt hätte,
was die Ziegen hier haben,
wäre ich der glücklichste Mensch
gewesen - das hätte gereicht.
Das hatte ich im Wald nicht.
Ich fror immer.
Ich friere auch heute noch,
wenn ich daran denke.
Kälte tut weh.
Und zwar ganz heftig.
Während seiner Zeit im Wald
hielt Seiler immer Ziegen.
Freunde seien das, treu und ehrlich,
ähnlich wie Hunde.
Anders als Menschen.
Komm her, komm!
Komm, Geissli!
Die sind jetzt zwölf Jahre alt.
Das sind die liebsten Kerle,
die man sich vorstellen kann.
Seine erste Ziege
fand er angekettet an einen Baum.
Seiler befreite sie
und kümmerte sich um sie,
bis sie eines Tages
friedlich einschlief,
den Kopf in seinem Schoss.
Es war ein Traum, dass sie so
in meinem Schoss gehen konnte.
Ohne ... Leid.
Sie verspürte kein Leid.
Sie ist einfach eingeschlafen,
das Herz hat einfach aufgehört.
Für mich war das wunderbar.
Ein wunderbarer Tod.
Wie wollen Sie selbst
gehen wollen?
Auch so.
In wessen Schoss wäre Ihr Kopf?
In dem meiner Katze.
Also bei einem Tier,
nicht bei einem Menschen.
Ja, bei einem Tier.
Ich bräuchte keinen Menschen dazu.
Jetzt kommt sie.
Ja, dir passiert doch nichts.
Hm?
Es war Anfang der 1960er-Jahre,
Seiler war kaum volljährig,
als sein jahrzehntelanger Leidensweg
begann.
Er galt
als arbeitsscheuer Tunichtgut,
der entmündigt und umerzogen gehörte.
Um sich dem Zugriff der Behörden zu
entziehen, sah er nur einen Ausweg:
Er versteckte sich im Wald.
Die Röhre ist nicht mehr hier.
Aber hier war ich - lange Zeit.
Man muss ins Dickicht hinein, weil
einen sonst die Förster entdecken.
Denn die ziehen durch den Wald.
Oder auch Wildhüter und Jäger.
Und dann heisst es: "Verschwinde!"
"Sonst holen wir die Polizei."
Anfangs lebte er in den Wäldern rund
um Aarau, wo er aufgewachsen war.
Später zog er als Vagabund
durch ganz Europa.
Eine solche Grube ist ideal.
Man kann Laub reintun,
natürlich trockenes.
Man ist geschützt,
man hat Sichtschutz.
Hier hätte ich
ein Lager einrichten können.
Und hier könnte man
eine Plane darüberhängen.
Eine grüne Plane.
Dann wird man
nicht so schnell gesehen.
Als Jungspund ...
ist das hier ein Jux.
Mit dem Alter
bekommt man aber Probleme.
In jener Zeit
sammelte Seiler leere Flaschen
und lebte mehr schlecht als recht
von deren Pfand.
Die Jahrzehnte im Wald
unter prekärsten Bedingungen
haben Spuren hinterlassen,
z.B. an seinen Füssen.
Die dauernde Feuchtigkeit
hat seine Zehennägel zerstört.
Die sind ganz dick.
Das ist ein Pilz.
Es nützt nichts, sie zu entfernen.
Das haben sie schon mehrmals getan.
Es bringt nichts.
Das bringt man nie mehr weg.
Er ist ein Überlebenskünstler,
sonst hätte er
dieses Leben als Obdachloser
nicht so lange durchgehalten.
Wovon haben Sie sich ernährt?
Hauptsächlich ...
... Brot und Cervelat.
Das war meine Hauptnahrung.
Brötchen, Cervelat,
vielleicht mal eine Suppe.
Aber das war schwieriger,
denn dazu braucht man ...
... einen Topf, der feuerfest ist.
Dann muss man das wieder rumtragen.
Meistens nahm ich Konservendosen.
Das geht auch.
Seilers Unheil nahm
im Alter von neun Jahren seinen Lauf:
Er hatte eine Hirnhautentzündung,
an der er fast gestorben wäre.
Danach war er in der Schule
unkonzentriert,
hatte Lernschwierigkeiten,
seine Lehre musste er abbrechen.
Seine Probleme wurden allerdings
nicht als Folgeschäden seiner
Hirnhautentzündung interpretiert,
sondern als Faulheit
und Charakterschwäche.
Wir reisen weiter zurück
in seine Vergangenheit,
zu seinem Elternhaus in Buchs/AG.
Nach dem Abbruch der Lehre
zog er sich in sein Zimmer zurück.
Diverse Arbeitsversuche scheiterten.
Die Behörden
wurden auf ihn aufmerksam.
Das war mein Zuhause -
in das ich nie zurückkehrte.
Er sollte auf eigenen Beinen stehen,
den Eltern nicht zur Last fallen.
Darum holten ihn eines Morgens
zwei Polizisten ab
und nahmen ihn mit auf den Posten.
"Du darfst keinen Kontakt
zu den Eltern, Geschwistern,
zu Freunden und Verwandten
aufnehmen. Keinen Kontakt."
"Wenn wir erfahren,
dass du Kontakt aufgenommen hast,
kommst du ins Erziehungsheim."
"Schluss, aus, Punkt.
Keine Diskussion."
Dann konnte ich wieder gehen.
Ich stand auf der Strasse
mit dem, was ich anhatte.
Eine Jacke, eine Hose, Schuhe -
finito.
Die Eltern,
selber überfordert mit dem Sohn
und eingeschüchtert durch
die Behörden, liessen es geschehen.
Tausende von Menschen
wurden im 20. Jh.
in der Schweiz Opfer
von behördlicher Willkür.
Unter dem Titel
"administrative Versorgung"
wurden die Grundrechte
von Betroffenen
jahrzehntelang systematisch verletzt.
Die Politik wehrte sich lange
gegen eine ernsthafte
historische Aufarbeitung
und wies eine finanzielle
Wiedergutmachung weit von sich.
Das änderte sich unter Simonetta
Sommaruga als Vorsteherin des EJPD.
Die Politik war unter Druck geraten,
weil der Unternehmer Guido Fluri
über 100'000 Unterschriften
für eine Initiative gesammelt hatte,
die Wiedergutmachung forderte.
Die Schweiz
entschuldigte sich offiziell
und sprach einen Solidaritäts-
beitrag von 25'000 Fr. pro Opfer.
Damit endete ein
jahrzehntelanger Kampf, oder besser:
Er hätte enden sollen.
Viele fallen in ein Loch,
weil sie keine Möglichkeit
mehr haben zu kämpfen,
denn im Prinzip
gibt es jetzt
die Anerkennung des Leids.
Aber weil viele
schwer traumatisiert sind,
wird es nie ein Ende haben.
Sie werden sich nie von dieser dra-
matischen Geschichte lösen können.
Und viele werden das
mit ins Grab nehmen.
Oha!
Das ist so gross,
dass es gar keinen Platz hat.
Seiler ist weit davon entfernt, mit
seiner Vergangenheit abzuschliessen.
Er besitzt schon ganze Berge
von Akten und fordert immer mehr an.
Er will alles wissen,
was ihm angetan wurde - und von wem.
Da ist sicher eine Rechnung dabei.
Es würde mich nicht wundern,
wenn eine Rechnung dabei wäre.
So habe ich mal ausgesehen.
* Düstere Klänge *
Dieses Leben
kann man nicht noch mal leben.
Das ist vorbei.
Kaputt und vorbei.
Dass ihm Unrecht geschehen ist,
hat er inzwischen schriftlich.
"Wir haben Ihr Gesuch geprüft
und festgestellt,
dass Sie ein Opfer
im Sinne des Gesetzes sind."
"Die Behörden anerkennen damit,
dass Ihnen Leid und Unrecht ...
... angetan worden ist ...
... das sich auf Ihr ...
.. auf Ihr ganzes Leben
ausgewirkt hat."
Das ist ... Wahnsinn.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Neben einer Entschuldigung des Bundes
hat er 25'000 Fr. bekommen.
Damit ist sein Fall
für die Behörden abgeschlossen,
für ihn allerdings noch lange nicht.
Nach allem, was ihm angetan worden
sei, stünde ihm mehr zu, sagt Seiler,
und hofft, dass die Behörden
das auch so sehen.
Ich verlange,
dass sie zu mir kommen und fragen:
"Was können wir tun, damit Sie ...
in Frieden gehen können?"
Das erwarte ich
von den Justizbehörden.
Diesen Satz erwarte ich von ihnen.
Ich glaube,
da können Sie lange warten.
Das stimmt wahrscheinlich,
denn diese Leute haben
keinen Anstand und keinen Respekt.
Keinen Anstand und keinen Respekt.
Seiler lebt seit einigen Jahren
nicht mehr im Wald,
aber Behörden, Beamte
und offizielle Stellen
sind für ihn
weiterhin ein rotes Tuch.
Wie ist Ihr Gefühl?
Nicht gut.
- Nicht gut?
Er befindet sich immer noch
im Clinch mit dem Betreibungsamt,
das sein Konto bei der
Berner Kantonalbank gesperrt hat.
Er steht v.a. beim Staat mit ein
paar Tausend Franken in der Kreide:
Steuern, Gerichtskosten, Bussen.
Weil ihm der Staat
jahrzehntelang Unrecht angetan habe,
schulde der Staat ihm Geld,
nicht umgekehrt, findet Seiler.
Der Staat und das Betreibungsamt
sehen es anders.
Und, was ist jetzt?
Das Konto ist "nicht verfügbar".
Durch das Betreibungsamt Burgdorf
ist das Konto nach wie vor gesperrt.
Das Betreibungsamt Burgdorf will sich
nicht vor der Kamera äussern,
teilt aber schriftlich mit,
Seilers Konto sei gesperrt worden,
weil er "jegliche Zusammenarbeit"
verweigere.
Es sei eine
"besondere Dringlichkeit" gegeben.
"Das Betreibungsamt
erachtet die Kontosperrung
gestützt auf die bundesgerichtliche
und kantonale Rechtsprechung
als zulässig,
da sich Horst Seiler
seit mehr als acht Monaten
dem Pfändungsvollzug entzieht."
Die 25'000 Fr.,
die er vom Bund bekommen hat,
hat er u.a. in ein Auto investiert.
Ein kleines Stück Freiheit für einen,
der immer wieder eingesperrt war.
Teilweise administrativ versorgt,
um ihn umzuerziehen.
Teilweise, weil er delinquierte.
Seiler landete z.B. wiederholt in
der Justizvollzugsanstalt Lenzburg.
Meist ging es um Vagabundismus
oder Zechprellerei.
Wenn er es im Winter
im Wald nicht mehr aushielt,
quartierte er sich in einem Gasthof
ein - und konnte nicht bezahlen.
Das waren Holztüren, Eichentüren.
Jetzt haben sie Metalltüren.
Das war alles schon so.
Auch dieser Absatz war schon.
Marcel Ruf, der heutige Direktor
der JVA Lenzburg,
nimmt sich Zeit für einen Rundgang.
Seiler war es ein Anliegen,
hierher zurückzukehren,
wo er mit einigen Unterbrüchen
Jahre verbracht hatte.
Der Direktor
führt ihn zu einer Zelle,
die noch genau so aussieht
wie damals,
als Seiler hier eingesperrt war.
Dieses Gitter ist nicht normal.
- So war es.
Bei einigen Sicherheitszellen
gab es diese.
Aber so eine hatten Sie wohl nicht.
- Nein, hatte ich nicht.
Aber das Bett war genau so.
Heute weiss man: Seiler wäre kein
Fall für Zwangsmassnahmen gewesen,
sondern für die IV.
Ein Gutachten
hat inzwischen festgestellt,
dass er infolge
seiner schweren Hirnhautentzündung
sein Leben lang weitgehend
erwerbsunfähig gewesen ist.
Damals hielt man ihn jedoch schlicht
für einen arbeitsscheuen Tunichtgut.
Die Staatsanwälte,
die Richter,
die Advokaten,
die Gemeindebehörden,
die Vormundschaftsbehörden
und alle jene,
die daran mitgearbeitet haben
und unser Leben zerstört haben,
das sind Tunichtgute.
Das sind sogenannte ...
... Nichtsnutze.
Denn sie haben keinen Nutzen.
Was die tun, ist Leben zu zerstören.
Das tun sie.
Und solche Leute
lässt man frei rumlaufen.
Seiler möchte eine Wiedergutmachung
für all die Jahre,
in denen ihm
eine IV zugestanden hätte.
Und für seine Zeit hinter Gittern.
Zur Zechprellerei
habe ihn der Staat quasi genötigt.
Später kamen allerdings
auch noch andere Delikte dazu:
Er mietete z.B. Autos
und verkaufte sie an Autoschieber,
um an Geld zu kommen.
Hätten mir
die Justizbehörden geholfen,
wie ich immer darum gebeten habe ...
"Helft mir doch, anstatt mich
ein Leben lang zu drangsalieren."
"Bietet mir doch Hand!
Bietet mir doch endlich mal Hand!"
Nein, ums Verrecken nicht.
Dann bin ich eben ausgerastet
und habe gesagt: "Jetzt reicht's",
und bin zum Täter geworden.
Tut Ihnen das leid?
Das ist eine zwiespältige Sache.
Einerseits sagt mir mein Gewissen:
"Das tut man nicht."
Ganz klar. Ein Mensch mit
einem Gewissen tut so etwas nicht.
Aber ich sage mir, in meinem
Notstand, in dem ich mich befand ...
... habe ich das aus ...
... aus Notwehr getan.
Und weil er aus Notwehr gehandelt
habe, treffe ihn keine Schuld,
findet Seiler -
schuld an allem sei der Staat.
Der habe ihm ja
erwiesenermassen Unrecht getan.
Das Bundesamt für Justiz
sieht es anders:
"Sie scheinen
von der Annahme auszugehen,
dass ein Opfer nach dem Bundesgesetz
über die Aufarbeitung
der fürsorgerischen Zwangsmassnahmen
und Fremdplatzierungen vor 1981
nicht mehr zur Rechenschaft gezogen
werden kann, wenn diese Person
aus einer (tatsächlichen oder
vermeintlichen) Notsituation heraus
straffällig geworden ist.
Diese Annahme ist jedoch falsch."
Straflosigkeit sei nicht vorgesehen.
Die in jungen Jahren erlittenen
Traumata haben nicht nur bei Seiler,
sondern bei vielen Betroffenen
zu brüchigen Biografien geführt,
sie für ihr Leben gezeichnet.
* Düstere Klänge *
In Mümliswil/SO
wurde ein ehemaliges Kinderheim
zu einer Gedenkstätte umgebaut:
ein Mahnmal gegen das Vergessen.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi miteinander.
(Alle) Grüezi.
Grüezi Herr Seiler. Baumgartner.
Wie ihr sicher wisst, bin ich einer
der sog. administrativ Versorgten.
Eine Mittelschulklasse aus
Hottingen/ZH hat Seiler gebeten,
ihnen von damals zu erzählen,
als jene am Rande der Gesellschaft
der vollen Härte eines willkürlichen
Staates schutzlos ausgeliefert waren.
Es ist eine Ohnmacht.
Man ist dem ausgesetzt
und kann sich nicht wehren.
Und wenn man sich wehrt,
wird man bestraft.
Die Mittelschüler
hören aus erster Hand,
wie schwer es ist, ein Leben,
das aus den Fugen geraten ist,
wieder in geordnete Bahnen zu lenken,
und dass die Versöhnung mit der
Vergangenheit damit anfangen kann,
sich selbst zu vergeben.
Das ist Glück im Leben.
Dass man am Ende des Lebens
sagen kann: "Ich habe so gelebt,
dass derjenige, der mir
dieses Leben gegeben hat, sagt:
"Okay, vieles ist schiefgelaufen,
aber ...
... du hast
das Beste daraus gemacht
und du hast mir
keine Schande gemacht."
Das ist Glück.
Also, ihr wisst jetzt,
was Glück ist.
Vier Jahre lang hat eine
unabhängige Expertenkommission
die administrativen Versorgungen in
der Schweiz historisch aufgearbeitet.
Kommissionspräsident Markus Notter
übergibt Bundesrätin
Karin Keller-Sutter
den Schlussbericht samt Empfehlungen.
In unserem Land ist Zehntausenden
von Frauen und Männern
Unrecht angetan
und Leid zugefügt worden.
Sie hatten lange
kein Gehör bekommen.
Unser Staat und unsere
direkte Demokratie leben davon,
dass wir die Stimmen
der Menschen in unserem Land hören.
In Ihrem Fall
und in Zehntausenden anderen Fällen
wurde dieses Credo nicht gelebt.
Im Gegenteil,
der Staat hat Sie mit seinem
Eingriff in Ihr Leben geschwächt.
Bundesrat und Parlament
haben sich entschuldigt
und das Unrecht anerkannt.
Der Staat hat nicht die Aufgabe,
seine Bürgerinnen und Bürger
zu bessern.
Er muss Sie, Ihre Freiheit und Ihre
Sicherheit schützen und stärken.
Meine Damen und Herren,
ich werde mich
mit aller Kraft dafür einsetzen,
dass das nicht vergessen geht.
Auch Seiler will nicht vergessen.
Ja, er kann nicht vergessen.
Er will von der Bundesrätin wissen,
wen er mit seinen weiteren
Forderungen nach Wiedergutmachung
angehen könnte.
Sie verweist ihn an den Kanton, in
dem sein Unglück seinen Anfang nahm:
den Aargau.
Ich habe heute noch
Albträume im Bett.
Ich habe Albträume
von diesen Verfolgungen,
die ich mein ganzes Leben lang
erleiden musste.
Man kann nicht einfach sagen:
"Strich drunter!"
Dieser Strich ist unmöglich.
* Langsame Mundharmonika-Klänge *
Seilers finanzielle Probleme haben
sich zwischenzeitlich entspannt.
Er hat das Betreibungsamt überlistet,
indem er ein neues Konto
bei einer anderen Bank eröffnet hat
und sich sein Geld
dorthin auszahlen liess.
Hier habe ich es hingebracht.
Die Rente für Februar.
2'700 Fr.
Ich könnte damit jassen gehen.
Einen Jass machen mit dem Geld.
Nein, zuerst muss ich
die Schulden zurückzahlen,
die entstanden sind, weil ich
letzten Monat kein Geld hatte.
Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Mir wird schon
wieder etwas einfallen.
Ich bin ...
... sehr beweglich
auf diesem Gebiet.
Ich bin beweglich,
ich weiss noch viele andere Wege.
Man muss sich
keine Sorgen um Sie machen?
Ganz sicher nicht.
Wenn einer 40 Jahre
ohne Geld überleben kann, im Wald,
dem muss keiner
etwas vormachen wollen.
Ganz sicher nicht.
Ich bin gewappnet.
Das Betreibungsamt hat die
Kontosperrung kurz darauf aufgehoben.
Der Kampf mit den Behörden ruht -
jedenfalls für den Moment.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Alexandra Duttweiler - 2020